dans un premier temps est très
curieusement d'ailleurs si nous avons
beaucoup dire affectueuse émergentes
rappelez-vous les épisodes donc celui ci
est due à un virus et un coronavirus le
précédent du tas virus dit amo la
responsable de maladies hémorragiques
dans les populations
nous avons eu d'autres épisodes du aussi
un décor la virus précédemment donc
beaucoup d émergence de ces dernières
années sont dues à des virus mais je
souhaite rappeler que généralement on
meurt dans le monde beaucoup plus de
maladies d'origine bactérienne qu'on
oublie très souvent je souhaite à le
rappeler d'infections dues à des virus
est généralement même les spécialistes
vous diront mais si on pense beaucoup
plus au virus c'est tout simplement
parce qu'ils se dispersent et se
transmettent beaucoup plus c'est
absolument pas vrai la bactérie
responsable de la coqueluche d'accord
plus lui-même est tout autant
transmissibles et contagieuse que ne
l'est un virus comme celui de la
rougeole par exemple faire c'est un
premier point et un deuxième point comme
illustré donc je suis sur la deuxième
dispositif tout en bas un travaux que
j'ai pu effectuer est publié eh bien on
observe beaucoup plus d'agents d'origine
animale qu'on va appeler d'origine
réseau nautique c'est le terme
scientifique qui vous est présenté tout
en bas que de maladies d'origine et à
transmission vectorielle par exemple
paludisme est avec la transmission
vectorielle ou que de maladies d'origine
contagieuses ou tout en bas que deux
maladies d'origine environnementale par
exemple la bactérie responsable du
tétanos et une clause prédit et bien
c'est une maladie d'origine
environnementale qu'on appelle une
synchro n'ose donc globalement nous
avons aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de deux
maladies d'origine
un réservoir et qui a infecté population
humaine sur terre avec une accélération
de ce phénomène depuis 30 à 40 ans
environ
donc troisième diapositives donc c'est
la troisième diapositives bien entendu
en incluant la page de titre
ici je me faisais illustré à partir d'un
dessin produit par les stylistes
d'atlanta ce qui se passe en réalité
dans les écosystèmes naturels donc tout
à gauche vous avez ce qu'on appelle un
cycle enjeux outils et que nous avions
le par la lbu par le passé l'habitude
d'appeler cycle cinématique où seul
viatique simplement parce que la plupart
d'entre eux se déroule en forêt est bien
certain nombre de d'organismes abrité
dans la diversité biologique qu'elle
soit d'origine tempéré haut ou plus
tropical et bien beaucoup de micro
organismes en réalité circulent ce sont
des centaines de millions d les voir des
milliards qui circulent dans la
biodiversité qui d'ailleurs sont plutôt
des formes non pathogènes plutôt
bénéfique car des commensaux de l'animal
ou dessein violent de l'animal et qui a
circulent dans ces environnements
donc ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec la
destruction des forêts tant comme
l'illustré si vous voulez en partie
médiane de cette illustration est bien
vous rapprocher des animaux a notamment
les animaux d'élevage on pense par
exemple à la déforestation au brésil et
qui va entraîner un développement de
l'agriculture mais aussi de l'élevage de
vous rapprocher soin des animaux
d'élevage domestique mais aussi des
animaux de la forêt vont venir se
raccrocher à des populations humaines et
donc aussi transmettre leur micro
organismes soin aux animaux qu'ils
rencontreront comme illustré en bandeau
centrale sur cette présentation mais
aussi à l'homme aujourd'hui et depuis 50
à 60 en 75 % des nouvelles infections a
paru chez l'humain son origine animale
le zoo nautique selon un transfert qui
vous est expliqué sur l'accélération du
phénomène est beaucoup plus importante
puisque dans l'histoire des infections à
les parasitoses humaines depuis environ
le néolithique sévèrement il ya moins
8000 à moins dix mille ans en arrière
jusqu'à l'actuelle
nous connaissions 72% de maladies
infectieuses et parasitaires humaine à
d'origine animale pardon affecté humain
or ces cinquante à soixante dernières
années nous sommes passés à 75 pour une
accélération de ce phénomène et cette
accélération de ce phénomène au salaire
du passage de micro-organismes de
l'animal sauvage vers les populations
humaines est due à une augmentation des
combats entre les uns et les autres dans
quatrième diapositives
ici je vous illustre juste une tendance
qui est à observer aujourd'hui à
découvrir comme l'illustrent cette
courbe une augmentation du nombre ici de
d'espèces virale écrit par la science et
la médecine
donc ça c'est une observation qu'on peut
faire à tous les niveaux c'est à dire
c'est aussi vrai pour les espèces de
bactéries est aussi vrai pour les
espèces de champignons parasites ça est
moins vrai pour les formes par l'asie en
particulier mais en général on observe
beaucoup plus aujourd'hui et ont décrit
beaucoup plus d'espèces giral d'espèces
bactériennes en particulier au cours du
temps et on le doit évidemment d'un
phénomène essentiel qui sont les progrès
très importants de la biologie
moléculaire aujourd'hui qui vous
permettre à travers du séquençage match
massive de décrire des nombreuses
espèces de virus ou de bactéries ou de
champignons parasites mais aussi au fait
que beaucoup de discipline beaucoup de
chercheurs et de médecins travaillent
sur cessions sous les yeux ce à travers
ces dieux de diapositives nous est donné
quelques dates de découverte de certains
virus ici je vais vous rappeler que la
description de virus ne vont rien dire
sur la description des gens pathogènes
la plupart du temps ces recherches sont
effectuées sur la base de séquençage
moderne séquençage moléculaire qui vous
décrire une séquence de virus mais
n'implique pas à le fait que ces virus
et bactéries soit pathogènes ou
hautement pathogène pour l'humain
donc il s'agit ici d'une forme de
taxonomie moderne de descriptions de
nouvelles espèces virales et
bactériennes donc la tendance
aujourd'hui est
dans ce sens de ce qu'on attend d'une
infectiologie exploratoire à la
description à un certain nombre de
nouvelles espèces de virus de bactéries
de professeurs mais aussi la diversité
biologique abrite en réalité des
centaines de millions voire des
milliards de ces micro-organismes voilà
je positive suivante donc celle qui vous
présente des cartes avec un fond vert et
des taches orange donc ici cette
diapositive vous présente sur la base
d'un travail effectué par les collègues
aux états unis les zones dans le monde
où il reste à décrire notamment des
virus dont certains pourraient se
révéler être un peu jeune pour l'espèce
humaine dans le futur dans vous voyez
tout en haut à gauche la carte générale
c'est le petit à qui vous donne les
tendances
aujourd'hui on observe de descriptions
de virus en général dont certains
peuvent se révéler revêtement pathogènes
pour moi et vous voyez que l'amérique
centrale et l'amérique du sud ou le nord
de l'amérique du sud sont des ce qu'on
appelle des causses porte des points de
chute les coins chauds pour la
découverte de nouvelles espèces de virus
on pourra y venir pour les explications
si vous souhaitez ensuite comment juste
un autre exemple un qui nous concerne
avec cette épique des pandémies pardon à
8,19 due à un virus coronavirus donc
n'ont par exemple pas en position
médiane horizontale la poésie la part
dont la carte petits dés il représente
un pictogramme de chauves-souris
ouvriers de même que l'amérique du sud
concentre beaucoup de virus d'origine
chez les chauves-souris en particulier
et donc vous êtes aujourd'hui où la
science est capable de déterminer les
zones qui représentent des hot spot
point chaud à la présence d'un virus
dont certains pourraient se révéler
contenant pathogènes ou pathogènes pour
l'espèce humaine mais aussi pour
d'autres animaux par ailleurs
positive suivante ici sur la base d'un
travail très récent que nous venons de
publier avec des collègues qui vous
donne une carte qui montre une carte du
monde avec les zones les plus sensibles
aujourd'hui quand tu as des nouvelles
infections à partir d'une origine zola
qui alors des de ceux-ci bleus car il y
en a beaucoup dans la littérature la
différence de cette carte de ce travail
par rapport aux précédents travaux c'est
que nous avons inclus des dimensions qui
sont souvent oubliée parce que vous avez
bien compris que dans la précédente
diapositives il s'agit de
essentiellement de la présence et la
distribution de virus d'origine animale
potentiellement ici nous avons inclus
d'autres paramètres et qui concerne bien
entendu la distribution des grands biome
forestier dans le monde mais aussi la
diversité biologique qu'on y trouve qui
est le réservoir en réalité de ces virus
et bactéries mais aussi la densité
humaine qui est un facteur extrêmement
important à considérer mais aussi
l'intrusion humaine c'est-à-dire les
toutes les phénomènes de pénétration des
populations humaines dans les grands bio
le forex et notamment pour le
développement de l'agriculture et de
l'élevage comment l'observent au brésil
là en particulier mais aussi en amérique
en afrique centrale au cameroun en
particulier où on a donné 10 ou en
général en asie qui est un autre
paramètre qui est la pauvreté les
populations et vous voyez ici par
rapport aux cartes qui sont produites
généralement les zones à fortes ria
forte risque de transmission de
nouvelles infections d'origine animale
aux populations humaines à étant
différente par rapport à ce que les
travaux précédents pouvait nous proposer
tout simplement parce que nous avons
inclus des dimensions d'exposition des
populations mais aussi le vénérable
d'état au travers de paramètres de
pauvreté qui sont extrêmement importants
pour comprendre la transmission
infectieuse
autrement dit à un virus ou une bactérie
ne le fait pas ou ne font pas la mallet
il vous faut énormément de paramètres
qui se croisent les uns les autres et
donc le l'exposition à travers les
pratiques et les usages la chasse
mais aussi le développement de
l'agriculture et de l'élevage dans les
zones intertropicales en particulier est
évidemment la pauvreté le la pauvreté et
la vulnérabilité des populations ont
toujours constitué le lit pour les
infections et c'est un paramètre
extrêmement important à prendre en
compte et qu'on oublie généralement
positives suivante c'est sur la base
d'autres aussi effectué d'ailleurs en
vue à la française dans le cadre d'un
l'index pour lequel j'avais la
responsabilité des recherches en santé
un magnifique dessin qui nous illustre
une scène habituelle dans les zones
intertropicales avec tout à gauche une
forêt primaire avec un certain nombre de
l'élément de la diversité biologique
comme vous voyez l'installation d'une
population avec cette case et puis
l'activité humaine
et puis tout au loin sur la partie
droite vous voyez il faut deviner une
grande ville et les taches vertes vous
illustre un âge en particulier un agent
ni comme une bactérie en particulier sur
lequel j'ai travaillé pendant ces quinze
dernières années qui est une
mycobactérie tout à fait identique à la
mycobactérie responsable de la lettre ou
de la tuberculose et qu'on n'a pas le
mycobacterium ulcerans sait qu'il est
responsable de ce qu'on appelle le
mystère de buruli en réalité c'est une
mycobactérie est abrité dans toutes les
zones humides intertropicale comme
beaucoup d'ailleurs l'agent affectueux
et au cours de ce phénomène de
déforestation c'est ce que je me propose
de vous représenter
à suivre eh bien au cours du phénomène
de déforestation
cette diapositive diapositives suivante
et vient l'écosystème est complètement
perturbé les communautés d'espèces qui
se retrouvent dans ces habitats
déforester sont modifiées certaines
espèces vont disparaître et en
particulier d'ailleurs les formes
prédatrice et vont laisser la place pour
la pullulation des formes qui sont
normalement les trois de ces prédateurs
qui ont disparu et au cours de ce
phénomène est bien de désorganisation
des communautés si certaines espèces
vont pouvoir proliférer parce qu'elles
sont ah non renate par les prédateurs
qui ont disparu à cause du phénomène de
déforestation
vont aussi favoriser le développement
d'une mycobactéries est une forme de
bactérie et qui est fameuse
mycobacterium ulcerans ce présent dans
tous les écosystèmes aquatiques
intertropicale est de provoquer cette
maladie dont vous voyez une première
image sur la droite qu'on appelle
l'ulcère de buruli qui vous fait des
ulcérations avec une progression d'un
feu bactérien sur la peau qui par une
toxine à vous détruire l'épiderme et le
derme et mettant les muscles annuler
comme guti et provoquant des infections
secondaires et interne la mort des
individus qui les contrats et donc vous
voyez quand même le phénomène de
déforestation notamment dans les zones
intertropicales ici c'est un travail que
nous avons effectué en guyane française
donc sur un territoire une région
française est bien le phénomène de
déforestation de part en part selon un
phénomène de cascade d'effets autant
traîné la pullulation d'un micro
organismes dans les environnements et
lorsque les personnes ont été exposées à
ce micro organisme
mais depuis la nuit des temps dans ces
micro dans ces écosystèmes en réalité
mais les perturbations humaines vont
créer une augmentation de sa charge de
l'environnement les personnes en contact
par des pratiques par des usages
notamment ici la pêche la récupération
de deux de crabes
comment le crabe de mangrove en
particulier comme en guyane française et
bien mettront en rencontres faites un
individu est exposé à ce jeune microbien
qui est là depuis la nuit des temps
en réalité prochaine diapositives et
bien c'est pour les personnes qui que
j'aurais perdu ses placards qui vous
montre un combat avec différentes
couleurs une carte mondiale avec
différentes couleurs ici sur la partie
gauche se sont globalement les
explications qu'on donne quant au
phénomène des meilleures chances de
maladies émergentes d'origine
environnementale ouzou nautique avec en
vert sur la partie gauche âge par le
camembert avait tout envers tout ce qui
concerne le changement d'usagé des sols
et puis l'intensification
l'intensification agricole
en général ces deux paramètres sont les
premiers sont en quelque sorte leicester
à odile au déclenchement de maladies
infectieuses émergentes tout simplement
parce que au travers de la modification
de l'usagé des sols pensons à la
déforestation dans les grands bio data
trop tôt qu est bien l'homme est exposé
à des germes qu'ils rencontrent les
germes étant installé là depuis a depuis
des milliers voire des millions d'années
bien est une composante de la diversité
biologique et au travers des pratiques
de l'agriculture et ensuite d'élevage il
est mise en rencontre avec ces germes
qui passent de l'un à l'autre et qui
provoque ces nouvelles infections
humaines mais aussi de l'animal est donc
vous voyez sur la carte en fonction des
pays et des régions et bien les
différents paramètres peuvent avoir plus
ou moins d'importance printemps dans un
premier temps et nous orientons nous
vers le brésil vous voyez que beaucoup
quand le petit camembert que vous voyez
sur la carte du brésil beaucoup de beaux
couteaux de de couleur verte
tout simplement parce que les
changements du zinc le sol et
l'intensification agricole et d'élevage
sont les premiers déterminant aux
infections émergentes que l'on rencontre
au brésil traversons de l'antique et
orientons nous maintenant vers l'afrique
centrale vous voyez qu'on est plutôt
dans des modes de couleur rouge ou
violette et bien ce sont pourris simo
coupe les pratiques de chasse et
pratiques de chasse traditionnelle en
particulier qui sont responsables de la
transmission infectieuse à partir de
germes microbiens d'origine animale ou
environnemental alors pourquoi je vous
ai de montrer je vous montre cette
diapositive tout simplement parce que
s'est produite à aller tenter à un
instant t pardon mais que cela peut
changer avec le temps au fur à mesure
que en afrique on pratiquera et on
développe la develop a comme au cameroun
une déforestation massive d'ailleurs
pour le développement en particulier du
panier à albi il est bien ses tâches
rouges ou roses que vous voyez pour
l'afrique centrale et bien passeront de
ceux de cette couleur rouge ou rose
revers puisque des déterminants
s'enchaîneront etc alors
le phénomène de déforestation prendra de
l'importance dans l'explication du
phénomène émergent ciel juste pour a
rappelé me reste quelques diapositives
pour respecter le temps en épidémiologie
et vous avez un certain nombre de
paramètres qui vous permettent
finalement de bien comprendre la
transmission affecte donc je suis sur
les petits pictogrammes que je faisais
présenté qui sont ici le couleur rouge
tout d'abord la taille de population
l'appel de population prenaient entre
une ville de grande importance est un
petit village vient ça va déterminer le
nombre d'individus potentiellement
suspect est petit maillot logist vous
dira que la taille de population donc
penser à des grandes villes versus des
villes de moindre importance et bien
seront un paramètre extrêmement
important pour la diffusion préfecture
bien entendu vous aurez comprendre
compris le sens de diffusion se fera
beaucoup plus facilement et rapidement
lorsque vos crise aurait des grandes
villes par rapport à des petites vive et
cela est d'autant plus vrai que vous
aurez donc bandeau centrale et densité
de population comme illustré sur ses
pieds groupe pictogrammes
plus il est élevé la la la transmission
est beaucoup plus important notamment
pour les agents à transmission
contagieuse de personne à personne ou
pour les maladies à transmission
vectorielle
d'autant plus que la densité de
population est importante parce qu'à val
déterminer ce qu'on appelle le taux de
contact
ensuite vous avez ce qu'on appelle la
connectivité entre les différentes
populations la connectivité c'est quoi
ces les foules d'individus à travers les
transports mais les transports aussi en
sont de produits et d'animaux y
circulent aujourd'hui dans le monde
beaucoup plus d'animaux notamment des
animaux domestiques et d'élevage
pendant que ses flux qu'on appelle de la
connectivité et bien vont déterminer les
flux et l'intensité des flux en personne
mais aussi en germe micro que c'est en
réalité ce qui s'est passé avec la
pandémie à qu'ovide 19 mai à une échelle
beaucoup club d'evian aujourd'hui
diapositives suivante quand les
personnes s'il s'agit de manière
positive ou maintenant vous avez un
disque vert et bien nous devons intégrer
en petits dés myologie moi j'appelle de
l'épidémiologie écologique
les continuités l'université ville donc
dans un premier temps tout en haut
je vous ai présenté un disque le vert
qui se rapproche d'un disque rouge le
disque rouge vous représente une grande
ville des disques huerre vous présente
une zone de forte biodiversité donc en
organisme que vous voyez et que vous
admirez mais aussi en microorganismes
puisqu'ils un fort lien entre lien à
l'autre mais à contacts entre des
grandes villes notamment dans le monde
intertropicale et des zones à forte
biodiversité favoriseront une
transmission infectieuse du compartiment
animal sauvage vers les populations
humaines par rapport à des
configurations où les zones de forte
divers diversité biologique en micro
organismes seront distant de dissiper
des deux villes de taille plus petite
est aussi plusieurs éloigné de ses deux
de ces zones de biodiversité
post it is suivante donc avec un bandeau
central des taches de couleur jaune qui
nous exprime a finalement la continuité
entre ce que vous est présentée au crest
la biodiversité et giné et dans la dans
l'interface vous avez le développement
des zones d'agriculture et d'élevage qui
vous sont présentés en jaune jaune ocre
eh bien c'est exactement la conformation
la topologie qui est en train de se
réaliser depuis 30 ans et en particulier
en asie du sud est
je vous une illustrée par ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui à bangkok en
particulier c'est à dire que dans les
autres séries urbaine nous avons
développé dans toutes ces régions du
monde les zones des zones de production
agricole et d'élevage qui sont à la fois
en contact avec les zones de forte
biodiversité dans les grands biome des
zones intertropicales est riche en
micro-organismes et puis la cip et bien
entendu riche en population humaine et
dans les zones d'interface donc elle
favorise les ponts de l'un à l'autre
c'est à dire les passages des animaux
sauvages vert
les animaux domestiques et d'élevage le
passage aux agriculteurs et aux éleveurs
qui bien entendu vendre leurs produits
au centre débit mais qui transmettent
des affections les centres des villes
par rapport à une autre
conformation en bandeau centrale mais
tout à droite où je vous présente une
topologie qu'il faudrait favoriser
c'est-à-dire pour éviter ces
transmissions via un ses comptes
positifs suivante je vous illustre
justement avec une carte satellite al de
d'une région au nord-est de bangkok
vous avez la carte de la thaïlande vous
aurez bangkok et puis vous avez un petit
rectangle en vert clair qui vous
illustre justement juste satellite al
qui vous est présenté tout en haut à
gauche
or exemple de vigne est d'ailleurs sur
cette zone sur son image ce qu'ali
talent des zones vers qu'ils ont les
zones de bio me forestier donkey concert
de la diversité biologique mais aussi
deux micro organismes bien entendu ah et
puis vous voyez des petites taches plus
ou moins verte
en tout cas des rectangles qui sont ces
zones d'élevage pratiques d'élevage et
l'agriculture mais qui sont à la fois au
contact de ces grands biome forestier
mais aussi à proximité des grandes
villes puisque ces zones périurbaines
mais autorise à nourrir les populations
au sort
tout en bas à droite vous avez en une
une illustration qui sont un axe dx vous
donne la distance et puis en axe y vous
donne la densité alors soit en animaux
soir en humain donc dans un premier
temps courbe noire avec une croix il
s'agit de la population la densité de
population ou au fur et à mesure qu'on
s'éloigne de bangkok tout à gauche êtes
au centre de bangkok et puis plus vous
allez sur la droite plus vous vous
éloignez de mongkok prenons un autre
exemple cours le rouge avec des petits
triangles et vous voyez que bien entendu
à bangkok vous avez moins de porcs
élevés bien entendu mais l'ours
vous sortez et que l'on cassé dans ces
zones périurbaines à 10 15 20 km de man
comme vous rencontrez les fortes
concentrations de porc et puis au cours
du temps vous avez une diminution de ces
concentration d'élevages bien entendu
que non aussi si vous voulez les poulets
c'est la courbe je croix rouge avec des
triangles pour les poulets grillés le
même phénomène c'est à dire que dans les
zones périurbaines vous trouvez les
animaux d'élevage dans ces zones à forte
concentration et plus vous vous déplacez
vous allez arriver avec les zones
d'élevage plus vous éloignez aussi de
bangkok où vous allez aller vers les
grands biome forestier interdit aux
clients que l'on trouve dans ces régions
et donc vous voyez là avec ce diagramme
la con on a organisé des écosystèmes
entreprises et qui favorise la
transmission infectieuse des zones est
des grands biome naturel voit les
populations humaines par l'intermède de
ces zones périurbaines où se sont
développées l'agriculture et l'élevage
ces 30 dernières années et pour ces
régions là aussi dire suivante et pour
conclure donc je ferai quelques constats
sur le dispositif de recherche national
et dans un premier temps je considère
que nous avons armée notre système de
recherche national et c'est beaucoup
moins vrai à l'étranger beaucoup moins
vrai chez nos collègues anglo-saxons
moi je je je passe ma vie plutôt
d'ailleurs à travailler à
l'international qu'au niveau français
pourquoi donc nous avons armée notre
système de recherche national pour
comprendre les infections les épidémies
et pandémies mais pas pour les anticiper
c'est à dire faire de la veille et de
l'action en amont à qui vous voulez nous
avons armée à notre dispositif de
recherches en autant de pompiers de
caserne de pompiers à est donc bien
entendu le pompier a absolument besoin
que le feu soit générée pour pouvoir les
atteindre autrement dit nous avons de
notre système de recherche beaucoup de
virologues ou de bactériologiste
pétillon besoin de cet objet absolument
besoin que le virus sortent du bois
permettez moi cette expression pour
pouvoir l'analyse et nous n'avons pas ou
très peu
sauf quelques quelques-uns a en
particulier mais nous sommes très très
peu à essayer de comprendre les raisons
à la naissance de ce feu de ces feux là
c'est à dire à ces émergences parce que
ça demande un travail de terrain
simplement d'un travail au long terme
alors que la recherche aujourd'hui exige
j'insiste sur ce point
ce verbe exige une production dans
l'immédiat
deuxième point nos modes de
compréhension doivent évoluer absolument
car nous sommes dans des systèmes
complexes non linéaire ils sont très
très proches
finalement deux suspects chaotique où
l'approché expérimentale est
difficilement possible lorsque vous
faites de la biologie le graal et 2
passes et al approche expérimentale pour
démontrer que votre cause est
responsable d'une conséquence et pour
démontrer que votre cause est bien
responsable est connue conséquence vous
développez l'expérimentation pour
démontrer plusieurs fois que votre cause
est bien responsable de cette même
conséquence
or les systèmes non linéaires ne vous
permet pas de développer
l'expérimentation d'autant que l'un
proche expérimentale se fait au
laboratoire et réduit la dimension des
possibles c'est à dire à des objets il
ya des dimensions le temps et l'espace
que vous pouvez analyser j'ai pour
habitude de dire que généralement vous
ne dépassez pas dans votre compréhension
les bordures d'une boîte de pétri
simplement parce que ces phénomènes sont
à très large échelle condamné
aujourd'hui vous le voyez bien avec ces
pandémies à des échelles globale et
c'est l'échec global vous ne pouvez pas
développé l'expérimental et
l'expérimentation à leur conscience
cette expérimentation est le graal de ce
qu'il faut faire
donc ici nous sommes devant un important
dilemme
je considère le suggérer ces sujets en
général en france devienne un très
rapidement un problème de médecine mais
ne le sont absolument pas au départ
puisque nous sommes dans des 1/4 face
vous avez bien compris en aide entre les
problèmes d'écologie d'agriculture
d'élevage mais aussi de sociologie
d'anthropologie de démographie ne
l'oublions pas c'est extrêmement
important et les causes en amont sont au
delà de la médecine seulement je
considère que en france nous avons une
tendance a refermé ses sujets et thèmes
autour de la médecine uniquement je
crois qu'il s'agit de mon avant-dernière
diapositives donc puisque la plupart de
ces phénomènes d'émergence sont
localisés dans les zones d'attentes il
ya très peu de l'affection émergentes
dans les zones tempérées
nous devons développer des recherches
dans le cadre d'accords bilatéraux dans
ces régions pour comprendre les tenants
et aboutissants de ces crises à ampleur
mondiale car il y en aura d'autres âge
dans dans l'interview pour le monde
d'autres avaient averti qu'il y en aura
d'autres et évidemment il y en a
d'autres parce que les biomes naturel
regorge de micro-organismes bien entendu
et il est vain de vouloir en faire une
estimation du nombre car ce sont des
centaines de millions voire des
milliards
bien entendu qu'ils existent l'appareil
de recherche national pour le
développement a été amputé ces dernières
années je dois assister ça peut il faut
absolument repenser nos politiques de
développement dans le cadre des
objectifs de l'agenda nommé 2030 des
nations unies et l'agencé française de
développement et à mon avis par rapport
à d'autres ça change de développement je
rencontre en connaît beaucoup à travers
mes activités et aussi on pourra parler
de lui s aide si vous voulez on est très
en retard sur ces approches et ses
perspectives ce n'est que à la fonte des
années 2010 qu'elle prenne en
considération ces phénomènes et c'est ce
qu'on appelle de la sauce teigne bilitis
heinz la science à 2 du développement de
la soutenable tout un ami il est parmi
autres poids l'agriculture et l'élevage
intensif étant des moteurs importants à
l'amplification la transmission
affectueuse la france et l'europe
doivent initier les approches et un
accompagnement de recherche et
d'expertisé
dans la transition agricole il égard aux
risques sanitaires ainsi bleus risque
sanitaire existe mais d'origine externe
à l'europe
il peut être en interne mais il ne
pourra arriver très rapidement sur notre
territoire infectés à des troupeaux et
des élevages entier et dont certaines
formes peuvent aussi passer à la
population humain il faut mettre en
place des modèles témoin un territoire
avec une compréhension de la révolution
donc celle approches actuelles et israël
où je suis qu'on m'a demandé de
développer au travers d'un programme
prioritaire qui est très
institutionnelle entre l'inra et le
cirad et l'institut de recherche pour le
développement de développement pour
intégrer la problématique du risque
sanitaire dans le cadre de la transition
et l'école internationale
on ne peut plus aujourd'hui pratique et
le développement agricoles et d'élevage
sans prendre en compte le risque
sanitaire
tel que nous le voyons aujourd'hui nous
ne comprenons jours et il faut à un
appui très fort de décideurs publics
surfer en orientation dernière bien
positif je pense nous avons un
positionnement et en particulier en
france très complexe par rapport à ce
qu'on appelle la recherche transversale
multidisciplinaire par rapport à l'hyper
spécialisation qui existent en france
avec une difficulté actuelle n'est
remise en contexte jusque dans la
recherche
tout simplement parce que nous avons
hyper spécialisés nos formations et que
la recherche transversale et les gens
qui ne les portes n'ont pas été à
suffisamment supporté ces trente
dernières années
personnellement ou à quelques-uns moi ma
recherche internationale n'est pas
financée par la france avait financé par
des grandes agences notamment nord
amérique
durant cette crise ah je me sentais
obligé de le faire parce que j'ai été
très sollicité durant de cette crise est
neuf dernières semaines
il ya une mise en évidence de la
complicité complexité organisationnelle
des institutions nationales françaises y
compris de recherche
j'ai eu très souvent été très sollicités
exactement sur la même chose au
participer à des rapports ou écrire des
notes par exemple cette note
exactement sur le même sujet venant de
différentes institutions exactement sur
le sur le sur le même thème et je ne
comprends pas très bien comment il n'y a
pas de d'organisation au niveau
supérieur entre différents départements
ministériels ou voir entre différents
ministres une somme d'agitation gros
mienne avec des multiples demandes en
parallèle qui sont non concertée avec
toujours que de créativité et beaucoup
de duplication il ya une difficulté en
france à produire de la synthèse sur ces
thématiques
je fais référence ce qu'on appelle les
centres cochrane en épidémiologie alors
que nous possédons par exemple à centre
de synthèse et d'un service sur la
biodiversité qui s'appelle le sésame qui
est pas ou peu dotées de moyens
financiers tout simplement parce qu'en
france on reste et on a une
compréhension très analytique des
phénomènes et on ne laisse pas
suffisamment de place aux approches de
synthèse qui vont souvent révéler des
vérités fausses ou vont contredire la
connaissance perceptuelle que l'on peut
avoir à partir d'études pluie donc je
vais terminer ici avec quelques
références et notamment donc le rapport
sur les maladies infectieuses émergentes
état de la situation et perspectives est
un document de l'état que j'ai cordes de
conques ordonné le professeur catherine
leport qui infectiologue à l'hôpital
bichat à paris
donc cela rapporte que nous avons
produit en 2011 cela alors que nous
étions au conseil de la santé publique
donc il est disponible et finalement ce
rapport raconte aussi très bien ce qui
se passe à l'heure actuelle à la
différence que nous avons vu nous avions
préconisé à l'époque les moyens
prophylactiques moyen prophylactique qui
ont été aujourd'hui perdu
et je crois que j'ai terminé il me reste
une diapositive ensuite pour les
quelques questions que vous courrez à
voir et je vous remercie pour votre
écoute et je suis disponible pour
répondre à vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur croc soit je
donnais tout de suite la parole à
guillaume chevrollier pour les premières
questions sur président sur professeurs
mais mes chers collègues merci pour cet
exposé tout à fait intéressant
d'ailleurs qui qui confirme un certain
nombre de thèses que j'avais déjà
entendu les auditions que j'ai menée sur
questions de biodiversité
on le voit ces sept années 2020 devait
être une grande année de la biodiversité
avec le congrès mondial pour la nature
et la cop15 le diversité en chine et on
voit qu'avec la pandémie que nous
connaissons il ya des très forts liens
avec les d impact sur notre
environnement sur la biodiversité et
vous en avez parlé à l'instant avec le
développement des zoonoses notamment
ouais je voulais vous poser quelques
questions en complément de votre
présentation
à aucun moment dans les cas que vous
avez présenté
vous n'avez parlé de la chine alors
qu'aujourd'hui si on est dans
l'actualité le colis de 19% son origine
dans une province chinoise est également
avec le lien sur les modes de
consommation alimentaire des chinois
dans qu'est ce que vous pouvez
développer sur sur cette question et sur
les comportements alimentaires
aujourd'hui de city créé ces pandémies
le point également de la biodiversité et
et est également à faire vous en avez
parlé parce qu'il conviendrait aussi de
d'accentuer les efforts pour faire
converger ces deux ces deux sujets et
après c'est de mise en oeuvre de
politiques publiques très très concrète
sur le sujet et la caisse que quelles
propositions on se calme ou le tir à
certain nombre de diagnostics mais
quelle proposition vous pourriez avancé
sur sur cette thématique là je pense à
celles qui faisaient partie d'ailleurs
des propositions pour l'agenda de
diversité à savoir le développement
d'aires protégées
[Musique]
comment lutter contre la déforestation
dans là aussi le lien avec
l'alimentation c'est défaut reste
l'avocat l'illustrent parfaitement bien
virus important en amérique du sud avec
un certain de produits qui viennent
d'amérique du sud dans des espaces
commerciaux comme l'europe donc comme
dans les espaces de consommation en
occident puisse régler les problèmes qui
se posent ailleurs donc de façon très
concrète et retrouver déséquilibre un
autre point sur le vous n'avez pas
évoqué sur le trafic d'animaux sauvages
et kehl quel impact la circulation du
virus est le vous l'avez évoqué sur la
nécessité d'avoir une recherche plus
importantes dans le domaine de la
biodiversité est aussi une parole de
peut-être plus entendue et des
chercheurs dans ce secteur-là auprès de
décideurs
aujourd'hui vous pourriez être membre
d'un conseil scientifique
vous pourriez le conseiller et
dernière question comment vous expliquer
aujourd'hui que le monde n'a pas fait
preuve d'une certaine impréparation face
à cette épidémie actuelle et à cette
crise sanitaire alors même que vous
l'avez démontré il y avait un certain
nombre de signaux bien avant on avait
des appels variable vingtaine d'années
le strass les phénomènes le phénomène de
la mondialisation et la rapidité des
échanges débat n'est pas nouveau
donc comment expliquer ce manque
d'anticipation
un certain nombre d'états merci merci
monsieur chevrolet 1 10 on a pas été
parfaite tout au long de votre propos
mais je pense que monsieur on va quand
même pouvoir répondre à vos questions et
interpellations
le professeur oui même merci merci pour
ses conséquences et ses 4 4 à 5
questions donc dans un premier temps
pourquoi la chine n'apparaît pas sur ces
cartes donc l'écart c'est toujours
intéressant mais il faut toujours se
méfier l'écart parce que il faut essayer
de comprendre quels sont les indicateurs
qui ont été mises en place pour les
dresser en fait est un souvent l'oubli
alors ça veut dire que tout simplement
si vous aviez appris comme par m
d'autres essais s'écartent les
construire disons la chasse la chasse la
chasse de 2,2 de viande de brousse en
particulier où la consommation de
produits extraits de la diversité
biologique bien entendu la chine serait
apparue beaucoup au pureau où je range
qu'elle ne l'est actuellement
donc les paramètres ont été utilisés ne
tiennent pas compte de deux les
pratiques de chasse en réalité mais en
revanche tiennent compte des ans des
niveaux de pauvreté des populations
encore les pratiques de chasse de ce que
je sais notamment dans les zones
tropicales sont toujours liés à des
populations les plus pauvres du monde
aussi d'ailleurs peut s'organiser à un
trafic plus ou moins fructueux pour les
personnes qu'ils organisent
voilà donc c'est tout simplement parce
que les paramètres n'ont pas été entrer
parce que la caisse
donc on nous nous posions dans cet
article la nounou n'était pas de sept
ans donc dans un premier temps voilà
j'ai répondu de ce que je sais et à des
cartes des produits dans la littérature
scientifique internationale d'ailleurs
la chine à l'exception du sud de la
chine ne figure pas dans des hawks potes
de diversité biologique en maladies
infectieuses émergentes a reçu de
l'autodafé le sud subtropicales et
tropicales oui mais c'est plutôt le la
thaïlande au laos l'indonésie qui sont
les hotspots de d'émergence telles
qu'elles ont été produites et identifier
ces dernières c'est les 10-15 dernières
années notamment par un programme
américain qui a vient d'être stoppée
d'ailleurs quand le président entrant le
deuxième question c'est là où j'ai eu
peut-être des difficultés la
biodiversité que faire alors bien
entendu vous avez bien compris que tout
les élèves et les interfaces que nous
produirons en tant que société humaine
et l'utilisation les usages de cette
biodiversité seront toujours des
pratiques d'ariste donc il faut à mon
avis mais je ne peux pas je sois bien
prétentieux de répondre à cela bien
entendu c'est quelque chose qui doit
être organisée à des niveaux nationaux
et internationaux des sanctuaires de
diversité biologique est attendu et
éviter au maximum les expositions les
expositions s'éteint c'est un sujet
extrêmement important on a oublié
jusqu en médecine des grandes classiques
de ce qu'est un risque à risque c'est la
multiplication entre des menaces des
dangers des expositions et la
vulnérabilité
il peut y avoir un danger mais si vous
n'êtes pas exposés à ce danger n'y a pas
de risque
d'accord et donc du coup il faut
favoriser à le développement d'aires
protégées éviter les expositions et
notamment les expositions qui peuvent se
faire au travers de la pratique de la
chasse en particulier mais aussi le
tourisme le tourisme a rendu responsable
de la transmission aussi en nous
l'oublions pas envers les animaux et en
particulier de grandpré nathan ne ferait
qu en afrique centrale
donc je pense aux grands sages de gyrus
de rougeole
qui ont exterminé des populations
entières population locale entières
devant son âge a donc c'est pas dans une
colonne dans un sens c'est aussi dans
d'autres domaines
alors comment lutter contre la
déforestation
c'est un véritable un véritable problème
leur voit bien que le problème est le
suivant la déforestation est un sujet
majeur pour la problématique du
changement climatique est un sujet
majeur aussi pour le développement de
l'agriculture et de l'élevage et les
risques que l'on peut rencontrer
derrière a eu le phénomène de
déforestation bien entendu on en revient
à mon premier point c'est à dire de
favoriser la création de grands espaces
naturels sanctuariser la chasse a été
effectivement un énorme problème à
l'heure actuelle mais plus que la chasse
parce que très curieusement c'est moins
la consommation de viande de brousse
boucanet qui seraient responsables l'ont
le par l'analogie on l'utilisait
énormément dans les explications de
transmission infectieuse de l'animal à
l'humain mais on a très peu finalement
d'évidence essai - la transmission par
la consommation de viande de brousse est
beaucoup plus par les contacts et les
expositions avec l'animal chassé c'est à
dire qui peut provoquer les blessures
qui peut par des expectorations des
fluides je pense aux urines mais aussi
sa salive à sa bave contaminé l'individu
chasseurs et c'est beaucoup plus par ces
phénomènes là et c'est voilà que les
transmissions se font à la lumière des
faits scientifiques un j'entends on
parle souvent que le virus où les deux
virus responsable du sida hiv 1 et a
chipé peut donc le premier le réservoir
fait des chasses à chaque pas est le
deuxième c'est le singe en hiver
d'afrique de l'ouest aurait été transmis
à l'humain par notamment la consommation
de viande de brousse ont dit la même
chose pour le virus ebola et en fait on
va en réalité on n'en sait rien pour la
pour la contamination
les premières contaminations de primaire
le virus de sida dans les années 1920 au
sud est du cameroun parce qu'on sait
identifier quasiment précisément
la localisation de ses premiers contacts
avec ses transmissions
personne n'est pas là pour faire une
photo de l'événement en question
c'est-à-dire favorisant la transmission
du virus de l'animal à l'humain viennent
la consommation de viande de brousse
vous voyez et donc du coup là on manque
de faits réels et d'ailleurs toutes les
études chez les collègues ici en france
notamment à l'institut tropical d'anvers
a récupéré à de la viande arrêté dans
les aéroports
donc ces lois et français n'ont rien
révélé
en cas de présence de virus en
particulier dans la viande boucanée
illégal
arrivé sur nos territoires alors des
photos ça veut pas dire que c'est viral
n'existe pas mais tout simplement dire
que les moléculaire utilisé ne l'est
révèle pas si elles sont à des densités
extrêmement faible la capacité de la
méthodologie impôts les révéler et de
temps 1 - c'est qu'ils percent et
pertinents mais en réalité on en trouve
deux des études que je que je connais on
n'en trouve pas outre qu'on attire le
trafic d'animaux sauvages et c'est tout
le problème très probablement avec ce
virus coronavirus star ce numéro 2 donc
en chine
le trafic d'animaux sauvages est un réel
problème mais quand je pense au trafic
d'animaux sauvages pour la consommation
humaine aux utilisations à issy les
écailles ou des os ou de certains
organes pour en faire des de l'île
poudre ou des extraits qui rend dans la
pharmacopée traditionnelle chinoise
si on pense bien la salle je pense aussi
à l'organisation finalement d'un trafic
d'animaux sauvages qu'on va essayer
aussi de récupérer pour alimenter les
nouveaux marché des animaux de compagnie
royale et cela a été responsable de
l'introduction d'un virus à tout à fait
équivalent au virus de la variole
variole humaine qu'on appelle le virus
de la variole du singe qu'on appelle en
anglais demande quels que soient les
risques est introduit dans les années
2003 à atlanta et qui est un virus qui
est aussi
pressé est renfermé très pathogène et
qui est issu des petits animaux qui ont
été introduits sur le marché américain
dans américain puisque les gens sont à
la recherche de nouveaux cotisent à
nîmes en compagnie donc on a introduit
des petits rongeurs des écureuils de
terre qui ont aussi introduites cette
forme virale extrêmement pas pesé alors
une sortie qu'une suite d'animaux
sauvages alain riel réel problème mais
comme je vous le dis et je connais très
bien l'amérique centrale l'amérique du
sud l'afrique de l'est l'afrique de
l'ouest
un peu moins l'asie du sud-est quoique
les trafics d'animaux sauvages au moins
la chasse dans un premier temps ce sont
toujours associés à des populations
extrêmement peau et bien entendu vent de
l'eure l'eure puis récupérés et derrière
il y à un marché illégal qui construit
et qui est plus ou moins lucratifs pour
les personnes qu'ils organisent donc il
faut bien aussi trouver les solutions
c'est une véritable problème durable
on ne compte pas interdire à ces
populations l'interdiction de chasse à
ces populations séculaire dans les
forêts africaines en amérique du sud et
centrale
si on ne trouve pas les moyens de
développer une agriculture et d'avoir
des métiers pour assurer leur propre
survie existence bien entendu et donc
c'est un important un problème mais vous
voyez que en amérique du sud
ça c'est d'ailleurs un sujet
d'anthropologie en amérique du sud les
populations amérindiennes qui ont la
pratique de chaque de chasse séculaire
traditionnelle et manière circulaire
c'est perrault je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit plus elles ont été plus
affectées que d'autres populations par
des virus ou des bactéries mortel en
tout cas il faudrait voir avec un autre
colloque sur ces sujets là mais moi je
ne suis pas j'ai pas lu de littérature
particulière à ce sujet
donc c'est un troisième question trafic
d'animaux notre en préparation je crois
que notre incompréhension elle est due
particulièrement peut-être en france
mais vous l'avez lu dans tous les médias
voulant rien entendu à la télévision
c'est un peu le syndrome du nuage de
tchernobyl qui s'arrête à la frontière
germano française dans ce cas là
pourquoi obtient respecter cette
direction eh bien la france est un peu
la même chose il faut savoir aussi qu au
niveau de la médecine comme dans tout
domaine d'activité vous avez des
sciences nobles et des sciences et des
domaines à moins nobles donc moi je
considère que toutes les recherches en
matière infectieuses l'infectiologie la
santé publique d'épidémiologie n'ont pas
du tout été privilégiée en france parce
que d'autres sciences plus nobles ont
une forme hégémonique sur cet appareil
là on nous on observe exactement la même
chose en biologie ou un virologue à
bongo plus de prestige qu un
bactériologiste et lorsque vous êtes
immunologie physiologie cellulaire
vous avez plus de prestige que des gens
travaillant dans d'autres activités de
la biologie donc je suis aujourd'hui
très persuadé que jusqu à l'intérieur
même de la médecine bien des gens de
certaines professions médecine dont on a
cru que nous étions possiblement
vulnérable à de nouvelles infections et
parasitose tout simplement parce que
nous les avons combattu et puis que de
toute façon nous trouverons les moyens à
2 soit les stopper soit de noob les
rires mais en réalité pour développer un
vaccin là le temps qu'il faut pour en
général développer un vaccin est entre
eux deux ans et 12 ans et en général
c'est plus beaucoup plus proche de 12
ans que de deux ans j'espère que cette
fois puisqu'un activités de recherche
beaucoup plus importante
on ira beaucoup plus vite mais lorsque
le vaccin est créé il faut bien entendu
le tester et ensuite il faut le passé en
stade commercial et c'est là aussi la
plupart du temps que ça peut achoppé
organique
donc moi mon explication dans notre
forme d'un préparation c'est tout
simplement parce que l'espèce humaine à
être aujourd'hui au sens de la médecine
plus du tout vulnérables ce type de
risque ou beaucoup moins
et si calais nous avons les moyens
technologiques et la connaissance pour
pouvoir les stopper voir les éradiquer
merci beaucoup je suis harcelé salle au
fond de ma pensée c'est une beaucoup de
discussions que j'ai mis ces dernières
années à ce sujet merci je vais prendre
maintenant des questions de sénateurs
qui ont manifesté leur souhait de vous
interroger monsieur le professeur je
prends des questions par groupes de
trois et j'ai demandé à madame de cidre
axel et en ligne 2 d'intervenir pour
vous poser la première question même de
ces dernières cibles
oui bonjour tout le monde merci monsieur
le président j'espère que vous
m'entendez tous très bien merci
oui professeur l'épidémie actuelle
effectivement appartient au groupe des
maladies zoonoses qu'il y en ait fait
espèces sauvages animaux domestiques
humain est vraiment je vous remercie de
la clarté de vos explications et des
illustrations que vous avez partagé avec
nous en introduction depuis des années
effectivement nous avons affronté
d'ailleurs d'autres maladies de ce type
on pense à ebola zika chikungunya et
autres h1n1 beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs
de maladies n'ont pas fait la une de
l'actualité non c'est bien qu'elles sont
présentées que et peut-être certaines se
déclareront à l'avenir
on constate également que le nombre est
en constante augmentation et qu'il nous
faudra peut-être apprendre à vivre avec
des épisodes épidémiques de plus en plus
fréquents le coc vie de 19 nous le
rappellent malheureusement
toutefois on sait aussi que ces espèces
virales sont parfois inoffensive pour
l'homme en fait d'ailleurs je pense que
la majorité d'entre elles le sont mais
même en faible pourcentage le potentiel
harry de risque en fait pour les
populations est réel et donc dans ce
contexte là
dans plusieurs entretiens vous avez
déploré effectivement la paire d'une
culture de la prévention des risques
épidémiologiques en france avec des
médecins des étudiants mais aussi des
décideurs politiques qui parfois et
surtout avant la pandémie donc que nous
traversons pensez peut-être que ces
maladies tropicales et infectieuses
n'était pas une menace se voir certaines
étaient vaincus
vous avez d'ailleurs parlé avec nous ce
matin de pompiers vous avez évoqué le
manque de prévention de nos dispositifs
de recherche nationaux effectivement les
conséquences sont importantes vous
l'avez rappelé cela induit une baisse d
enseignement épidémiologique et donc des
connaissances mais aussi provoquer vous
l'avez également rappelé des baisses de
crédits budgétaires dans la recherche
contre ces maladies
alors mes questions évidemment vous
l'avez deviné vont porter là dessus je
voulais savoir ce que vous pensez
est ce qu'il faut en réalité pensez vous
qu'il faille modifier nos enseignements
de médecine on va dire un peu
particulièrement pour intéresser à ces
sciences et de façon plus générale la
formation pour mieux prendre en compte
le lien qu'il ya entre santé et
environnement qui est plus que jamais
important aujourd'hui
ne pensez vous pas aussi qu'il faille
développer à travers une polo politique
peut-être plus volontaire dans ce sens
là la prévention et les sciences
épidémiologique
si oui quelles sont les pistes en fait
de réflexion que vous voyez que vous
voyez vous dans votre domaine et
qu'attendez-vous des évolutions voire
peut-être des bouleversements de la
recherche la prévention pour faire face
à toutes ces pandémies à venir
et si oui là encore pouvez vous dire
lesquelles et quels sont vos réflexions
merci beaucoup merci un de sidra que je
donne la parole à monsieur gold pm sur
le gâteau donc monsieur gold puis je
demander d'être relativement brève dans
vos questions parce que j'ai beaucoup de
demandes de parole donc ce n'est pas
parce qu'on est à distance qu'il ne faut
pas respecter la règle des deux minutes
monsieur gold monsieur le professeur
dans un article que vous avez récemment
publié
et vous évoqué la nécessité de
promouvoir une nouvelle organisation
mondiale plus respectueux des
engagements de l'agenda 2030 des nations
unies des collectivités locales sont des
acteurs à part entière il dit cet
objectif de cet agenda notamment à
travers l'élaboration des plans climat
énergie territoriaux ou encore la mise
en oeuvre d'une politique sur les
espaces naturels sensibles qui
concernent 73% de départements français
quelle place que tu occupes est
selon-vous l'échelle territoriale locale
dans ce nécessaire changement mondial
c'est les moyens qui sont accordées par
l'état sont ils selon vous suffisant à
la fois en termes humains et financiers
je suis allé très vite
j'espère avoir respecté longtemps merci
merci beaucoup monsieur globe monsieur
houlgate
merci monsieur le président bonjour à
tous merci à vous professeur pour
l'éclairage que vous nous apportez ma
question va faire le grand écart avec
celle de monsieur gold désormais donc je
pense que tout le monde est d'accord sur
le constat mais néanmoins il semblerait
que nous ayons entre ouvert la boîte de
pandore d'où s'est échappé le
coronavirus et que refermer cette boîte
en modifiant nos pratiques humaines
demandera du temps
même si même si c'est vrai le programme
de développement durable des nations
unies à l'horizon 2030 est une bonne
chose et est donc ma question est la
suivante c'est que le pompier en chef
c'est quand même l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
la pandémie de grippe h1n1 a été la
première pandémie du 21ème siècle
elle a été aussi la première pandémie
depuis l'adoption par les 196 pays du
règlement sanitaire international de
l'om est-ce alors il semblerait
maintenant on s'enorgueillit à l'époque
en disant que ce rs il y avait avait été
robuste il semblerait maintenant que
l'on se rend compte qu'il soit dépassé
donc ma question c'est comment modifier
ce qu'il faut modifier selon vous le
règlement sanitaire international selon
quelles modalités
et est-ce que puisque vous
dites que vous êtes pompiers est ce que
vous pensez même si ce sont des modèles
complexes que l'on peut néanmoins
modéliser aux hôtes au démarrage la
propagation d'une épidémie je vous en
remercie merci beaucoup je le gaz sur le
professeur pour répondre aux questions
dam de ses drague de monsieur gosse des
et de monsieur houlgate
tout d'abord merci pour cette
consécration donc trente professeurs
d'infectiologie français qui s'appelait
charles école avait l'habitude de dire
qu'un nom agents microbiens devient pas
de jeunes partir constance et non pas
par nécessité a donc il devient par
circonstances parce que c'est l'humain à
travers ses activités ces pratiques qui
organise finalement son transfert et
qu'il leur en quelque sorte un peu jeune
donc ce sont aujourd'hui nos activités à
tous les tous les niveaux d'échelle à et
notamment aussi plus globaux à qui
rendent ces micro organismes pathogènes
par les activités que nous organisons
mais ça a été un des éléments de ma
présente et transformant des
enseignements mais aussi large enseigne
ici en médecine à montpellier à angers
aussi et puis à paris à manière plus ou
moins permanente à paris où je peux être
aussi appelé marc gales à montpellier
donc ce dont je me rends compte c'est
que il ya beaucoup de pertes de
connaissance bien entendu sur ces sujets
qui nous intéresse c'est à dire
environnement et santé
je pense qu'il serait pertinent que
certaines écoles de médecine sa faim de
facultés en france et pas toutes se
spécialise sur ces sujets là vous voyez
il ya aussi mais beaucoup d'idées qui se
développe sur l'apport de la théorie de
l'évolution dans la compréhension de la
genèse de certaines maladies
infectieuses chroniques et je pense
qu'il serait important que certaines
écoles de médecine certaines facultés de
médecine nationale a encore une fois pas
tout se spécialise en formant des jeunes
médecins qui aura les esprits un peu
plus orienté vers des approches
évolutive des approches écolo écologie
bleus le sujet de la résistance 68 ans
était encore aux antibiotiques dans ma
spécialité
ça fait cinquante ou soixante ans on
n'arrête pas de dire intentions tous les
cinq ans environ vous aurez la
résistance appelle molécules les
portants on a continué à produire des
molécules non ça c'est dans mon domaine
d'activité quelque chose que l'on entré
en ondes très très bien très vite et que
l'on comprend en réalité
donc je pense qu'il faut favoriser
certaines et le développement de
certaines facultés de médecine et les
ouvrir à d'autres disciplines en
particulier beaucoup plus au science
écologique évolutif
elles ne le font actuellement ça c'est
j'en suis intimement convaincu j'ai été
formé gelé des unités d'enseignement en
parasitologie en pathologie et à
l'époque dans les années 87 des médecins
qui vous enseigner mais ce cas des
médecins qui était très grand
naturaliste hotfix connaissait très bien
le terrain qu'ils connaissaient autre
chose que la médecine où je pense qu'il
est important de revenir à ça alors on
en a quelques-uns est très simple de
manière presque d'intéressant ces
médecins et des esprits un peu avec une
vision très globale voulais retrouver
chez les médecins du service de santé
vous les trouvez bien entendu chez
certains médecins dans les ong vous
voulez trouver aussi à l'institut de
recherche pour le développement où vous
avez des médecins qui sont d'abord des
gens le terrain qu'ils connaissent très
bien les sociétés et qui ne font pas à
vous voyez que de la biologie ils vont
travailler sur les problèmes d'interface
entre une infection et le niveau de
pauvreté les individus leur niveau de
nutrition nutritionnelle ou de
malnutrition qui sont aussi les terrains
très favorable à holly holliday
infections les parasitoses donc moi je
préconise un retour au retour au terrain
je suis assez fidèle et c'est ce qui
manque au cou en mon sens de 2,2 sache
terrain
c'est extrêmement important comprendre
la réalité du monde donc il y avait une
tradition française en médecine à ce que
beaucoup de médecins alors je ne suis
pas médecin je tiens à le dire mais
beaucoup de nos médecins et des
générations les les moules et les plus
âgés avaient l'habitude de partir dans
ces web dans des ong médecins sans
frontières médecins
monde est pratiqué pendant deux ans
trois ans aux cayes landes au congo ou
ailleurs et donc de vraiment connaître
ces problématiques mais de connaître ces
problématiques pour le terrain donc
c'est à dire aussi discuter avec les
populations
ça semble important qu'on y revienne à
la médecine est devenue une médecine
très individualisé très technologique
très nucléaire très réparatrice alors
qu'une connaissance le lol la première
alerte a l'air dans le système dans les
systèmes affectio et bien ce sont les
gens qui connaissent les infections et
qui sont sur le terrain qui vont
diagnostiquer rapidement les premiers
cas c'est vrai aussi pour les sciences
vétérinaires qu'ils le feront que chez
les animaux
donc on a perdu un peu cette culture là
il faut absolument la retrouver moi je
considère parce que ce sont les premiers
garants du système dallaire est donc
derrière ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
former à ces pratiques nos partenaires
des pays du sud c'est à dire on a on a
aujourd'hui d'importants problèmes sur
des problèmes de diagnostic à la il ya
certaines pathologies qui sont très
difficiles et celles sur lesquelles je
travaille en particulier où il ya des
confusions énormes qui sont faites vous
voyez l'ulcère de buruli qui vous
propulse faire donc je vous avais montré
deux ou trois photos nous avons les
spécialistes en guyane française qui
sont capables de les détecter mais
partout ailleurs
la maladie n'est pas présente au brésil
il ya aucune raison de penser que la
maladie ne soit pas présente au brésil
ce sont les mêmes qui d'écosystèmes qui
héberge les mêmes germes microbiens mais
la maladie est catalogué plutôt au
brésil comme être une lettre manuscrite
année alors que c'est très probablement
dans de nombreux cas de l'ulcère de
buruli
vous voyez il ya un énorme problème de
diagnostic à la base donc moi je
préconiserais voilà et je préconiserais
un retour aux terrains autour
information un peu dur ça semble
extrêmement important car elle était
perdue
orizet les écoles de médecine ou les dix
lits à la désorientation
multidisciplinaire transversale on en a
très nettement besoin mon avis
en prévention et si on s'était démis
biologique ça c'est un travail de fond
je vous indique que je passais plus
montant allait trancher dans les grandes
écoles de santé public britannique ou
nord-américaine tout simplement parce
qu'il ya cette culture en amont plutôt
que cette culture curative comme on l'a
en france les essais de travailler sur
les déterminants de santé
c'est un des grands classiques de la
santé publique d'épidémiologie
travailler sur les circonstances qui
vont faire qu'une population sont
affectées et infectées dans ce cas là ou
pas là ça me semble extrêmement
important mais sur les dix qu'en france
en particulier
ça a été mal ou déconsidérer au cours du
temps voilà où je pense que là il faut
il faut donner la possibilité à ces
domaines d'activité laisse la santé
publique l'épidémiologie les aspects
santé environnement dont je dois faire
une petite parenthèse que je vais vite
refermée c'est que santé environnement
france est conçu dans une perception
extrêmement régler comment parler de
santé environnement en france
exclusivement j'entends ou par les deux
des aspects maladies chroniques
toxicologie écotoxicologie et que ce
domaine s'est lui même fermé par rapport
à ce que je représente ici aujourd'hui à
la section mais qui a une forte
interfaces interfaces avec avec
l'environnement donc dans le monde anglo
saxon prendre en matière de santé
environnement on y inclut ce que je vous
ai présenté alors qu'en france on le
faire on va aussi d'ailleurs le
comprendre 11
je pense avoir répondu pour la première
série de questions bien entendu je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas de réponses à toutes ces
questions
encore une fois qu'il faut favoriser les
approches de les approches de terrain et
notamment avec nos partenaires ça me
semble essentiel et notamment parce que
les premiers garants du système d'
alerte affectueux et merci sont les gens
qui sont à caractériser a terminé au
plus haut plus vite l apparition de ses
intérêts
et bien entendu on le voit avec
l'épisode chinois qu'il est important
dans ces systèmes dallaire que les
personnes qui la pratiquent ne soit pas
interdit de le faire elle ne soit pas
condamné comme ça a pu l'être en chine
donc promouvoir ensuite une nouvelle
organisation mondiale l'importance des
échelles locale m'a pour moi il me
semble et c'est vers là que devrait
s'orienter à mon avis je le dis de
manière individuelle et 13,1 mais je
pense que inra et aujourd'hui que je
représente est tout à fait d'accord à ce
que en france en territoire j'entends
qu'il ya des décisions qui soient prises
pour des activités des désorientations
en territoire de pratiques agricoles
d'élevage respectueuse de
l'environnement respectueuse des hommes
il a entendu des femmes quand je parle
comme je parle en tant qu'espèce bien
entendu excusez-moi responsable des
trajectoires de chaque territoire
moi ça me semble important dans la
mesure où ce pourrait être d autant
d'initiatives prises par des communautés
locales en territoire ils choisissent
des trajectoires que nous pouvons suivre
est rivé sur lesquels nous pouvons
analyser à quid des bénéfices à ces
développements mais aussi des risques
derrière sachant que le développement
d'une agriculture intensive en europe
bien entendu et d'un élevage intensif
est aussi à risque de transmission
infectieuse me semble important de
laisser ses initiatives en territoire se
développer avec bien entendu un retour
aux races animales moi ça me semble
essentiel car elles ont génétiquement
garante d'une plus grande résilience
face à ces infections et parasites aux
ça me semble important mais c'est aussi
vrai dans le domaine végétal vous parlez
de variétés extrêmement important et là
on parle bien de diversité biologique
diversité biologique a eu à notre niveau
qui est celui de la diversité génétique
qu'il me semble essentiel le
réintroduire dans nos systèmes agricoles
et d'élevage donc je pense en priorité
aux échelles locales ya toutes ces
initiatives en matière en matière de
des deux pratiques de développement et
de collaboration avec des partenaires ou
du sud on a bien vu toutes ces dernières
années moi je suis très sensible à ça à
des jumelages entre certaines villes et
certaines places certaines villes
certains villages sur un territoire
notamment nationaux ici en france avec
certains autres territoires queen au
mali au sénégal ou ailleurs je suis trop
sensible et c'est par là que ça doit
aussi rendre tous ensemble
dernière question entre alors nous avons
ouvert la boîte de pandore le rôle de
ems du règlement sanitaire international
alors c'est un problème quand même aussi
le politique en moi il me semble que les
organisations internationales comme le
ms mais il y en a bien d'autres ont
perdu de la puissance moi je suis assez
à titre individuel à ces catastrophes et
par la quasi absence de l'om est dans le
discours
actuellement ce sont des institutions
qui ont été au cours du temps de moins
en moins bien dotés je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir à une réorganisation de ses
institutions réorganisation de ses
institutions mais aussi à la lumière de
ce que vous dit à la lumière des faits
aujourd'hui que nous avons des
recherches scientifiques à 7,1 me semble
important je pense que quelquefois il
n'y a pas assez l'assimilation par ces
institutions de ce qui se fait dans le
domaine scientifique par exemple à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu un directeur de
département science environnementale et
santé à la msa toujours très bien marché
je vous donner des exemples et les
périodes durant lesquelles s'est très
bien marché et à chaque fois qu'il n'y
en a plus eu pour des problèmes soient
financiers ou soit de résistance et on a
l'eau mais c'est bien les aspects santé
environnement ont été beaucoup moins
considéré bien entendu donc voilà votre
santé est la mienne mais à suisse des
animaux et celle des plantes dépend des
conditions environnementales dans lequel
ces populations vont vont vivre bien
d'autres
ça c'est une dimension extrêmement
importante et c'est aux politiques de
l'exprimer à ces organisations
il me semble que beaucoup de ces
institutions aussi où sont tenus par des
classes d'âge moi j'avais partie d'une
classe d'âge où je vais vers les 60 ans
mais qui ont été formés à des pratiques
au sortir de la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est à dire dans les années 60 puis ont
été formés à des pratiques souvent dans
le domaine agricole et d'élevage de la
zootechnie et qui n'ont pas non plus on
comprend tout à fait très bien non pas
au cours du temps assimilé toutes ces
nouvelles notions a par exemple sur
l'élevage c'est très important de
considérer le rôle que l'élevage mondial
peut avoir sur le changement climatique
c'est extrêmement important c'est de
l'ordre de 18 à 22% des dégagements de
gaz produit par les animaux d'élevage
omis sur la planète qui contribuent au
changement climatique des notions qui
n'était pas développée dans les années
60 et 70 dans les grandes écoles
vétérinaires et elle-même libyen alors
c'est un problème est effectivement très
politique je pense que la france en
particulier je sais que le ministère des
affaires étrangères au pm est très
sensible à ce sujet je sais aussi que
par l'intermédiaire de l'iddri si vous
connaissez il ya toute une réflexion qui
est portée actuellement et la france
avec l'europe doivent être un
mobilisateur un niveau international
pour une reprise en main de séance
elles ont été en particulier le hamas
très déstabilisés ont été re 1,1 comme
en afrique par les financements venant
des grandes fondations je pense à des
nations des métis ou d'autres où ça pu
être aussi terrible pour le ms beaucoup
moins dotées que ce que peut développer
et fournir une fondation comme comme
celles là paraissent enfin ça c'est les
sujets qui me semble très préoccupant
alors actuelle est ce qu'on peut
modéliser de la propagation d'une
épidémie alors la maison c'est toujours
très difficile vous voyez nous sommes
capables de produire des cartes ont des
cartes plus ou moins grossières
là la naissance de cette épidémie a été
très bien vu par un programme américain
qui s'appelle us predict qui sont que
qui est développé par des collègues et
amis américains le nord américain des
états unis d'amérique et qui vient
d'être stoppée que simplement parce
qu'ils collaboraient avec le laboratoire
de virologie de one dont ils auraient
formé d'ailleurs la virologue
donc ils ont très bien prévu cette
épidémie sa naissance son éclosion donc
on est capable de le faire de manière
assez assez assez assez grossière parce
que on manque bien entendu de deux ans
de travaux en manque de ressources
humaines 1 nous sommes 4 5 6 et
chercheur senior en france est sorti un
peu plus dans le détail quand celui que
je vous ai présenté nous sommes
peut-être à peine deux ou trois et nous
sommes environ des jeunes chercheurs que
nous allons fermer une quinzaine
vingtaine guerre pesant environ et la
plupart du temps avec des difficultés
pour obtenir des crédits évidemment
parce que nous faisons pas où nous faut
nous produisons que la science de
corrélation est donc je reviens sur ma
discussion pour qu'est ce que la science
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que le fait
scientifique à la lumière de résultats
qui sont plus des résultats de système
chaotique non linéaire lorsqu'on ne peut
pas démontrer réellement par
l'expérimentation que la cause est
vraiment responsable de cette
conséquence puisque on est dans des
systèmes non linéaire que les
équilibristes et mollo gabelle et chaîne
de causalité ou une cause sacrée est une
conséquence mais cette conséquence un
même devient la cause d'autres choses
etc
et c'est ça et se passe aujourd'hui est
donc je pense que je considère que la
science et le formalisme de la science
active été construits ne permet plus de
répondre à ces questions à planétaire
aujourd'hui qu'il va falloir
sérieusement se poser des questions si
nous sommes capables de modéliser mais
insuffisamment parce que nous sommes
très très peu nombreux
encore une fois le feu à le faire et que
c'est suivait là ce sont en particulier
les chercheurs britanniques mais aussi
et surtout nord-américain qui
1/2 nain domine le sujet donc nous
sommes quelques français mais un
collaborer avec eux et pas un collaborer
avec la recherche française
merci je vais donner la parole à présent
à monsieur marchand qui doit être en
ligne
monsieur marchand
oui est-ce que vous m'entendez président
parfaitement monsieur marchand
bonjour président et bonjour au collet
qui sont présents merci professeur pour
cette présentation des plus complètes et
fort intéressante
je voudrais revenir sur un sujet que
vous venez d'évoquer s'agissant de
l'agriculture de l'élevage intensif et
des préconisations que vous faites pour
aller vers le local puisque avec ma
collègue nelly tocqueville
nous avons mis en place un groupe de
travail dans le cadre de nos travaux du
moment pour réfléchir justement sur ces
questions d'alimentation durable et
d'alimentation locale et donc de
consommation à l'aune de cette crise
sanitaire en y intégrant bien évidemment
donc les enjeux en terme de santé
publique et en terme
et puis des no logic c'est vrai que au
regard ne m'avait pas forcément cité le
virus nipah en malaisie mais on voit
bien que la corrélation entre la
déforestation l'élevage intensif de
porcs a permis effectivement
malheureusement l'émergence et quand on
parle d'alimentation donc on parle bien
évidemment de consommation consommation
responsable et je partage votre envie
sur le rôle du local et la liaison très
étroite à voir avec les autorités
locales parce que finalement dû sur les
consommateurs qui ont un rôle à jouer en
faisant le choix d'une viande issue d'un
des pages locales on refusera l'élevage
intensif en préférant les huiles les
farines cultivés et fabriqués par des
petits producteurs on n'arrivera sans
doute à faire changer l'industrie
agroalimentaire et je voudrais avoir
votre avis notre regard puisque on a
auditionné l'inra me et est notamment
été posé la question des projets
alimentaire territoriaux est ce que vous
considérez aujourd'hui que sur ses
projets alimentaire territoriaux la
dimension sanitaire à dimension épique
guinot logique doit faire partie des
items les plus importants et est ce que
vous pensez puisque vous
wauquiez le manque d'anticipation que
ces projets alimentaire territoriaux
peuvent contribuer à l'échelle locale
justement à permettre de mieux anticiper
de futures épidémies
merci merci beaucoup monsieur marchand
monsieur gontard mh oui merci monsieur
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
professeur pour votre exposé
particulièrement particulièrement
complet vous avez déjà répondu à
beaucoup de choses
vous avez notamment dit que tous les
virus ne déclenchaient pas une pandémie
mais par contre que l'action de l'humain
favorisés justement c'est cette pandémie
avec avec l'appauvrissement des
ressources la dégradation de la
biodiversité l'artificialisation des
sols par les eaux sida de la pauvreté
qui est aussi un facteur un facteur
important
et moi je voulais revenir justement
aussi sur ce que disait mon collègue
juste à l'instant sur la question
agricole et peut-être sur les remèdes
environnementaux pour prévenir de
nouvelles épidémies savoir s'il y avait
une priorité en tout cas sur les actions
à mener
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
mériteriez en avant dans les choses
qu'il faut sur lesquels il faut agir en
particulier et c'est vrai que moi je
pense que santé alimentation
environnement et donc du coup la
question agricole me paraît me paraît
particulièrement importante on à la
discussion sur la politique agricole
commune
les questions sur les traités de libre
échange et je pense notamment le bon
s'était dit le développement de la de la
polyculture la limite limitation de
l'élevage industriel ou intensif de
privilégier les protéines végétales par
exemple sont sont des pistes qui me
paraissent qui me paraissent importantes
et qui me paraissent d'autant plus
importantes qu'elles rejoignent aussi ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour être plus
forts face aux aléas climatiques et au
risque climatique parce qu'on a vu que
c'est sur ces mêmes lieux levier sur
lequel il faudrait agir voudrais avoir
votre avis là-dessus et puis sur la
question de la recherche justement dont
vous avez parlé sur la biodiversité pour
appréhender les dimensions
épidémiologique au fond notre collègue
franck courchamp qui disait que 75 à 80%
du système vivant n'est pas répertorié
soit bactéries champignons virus il
reste énormément à faire là dessus et
donc est ce que vous pensez que
justement on se priorise suffisamment
sûre c'est sur ces questions
et sur cette question de la biodiversité
merci beaucoup merci monsieur gontard je
donne la parole à monsieur jojo
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur guingamp merci
beaucoup monsieur guégan pour vos propos
illustrant que la relation entre
pandémie et destruction des écosystèmes
n'est plus à établir dans la crise
actuelle est fondamentalement une crise
écologique globale mais sans verser dans
biocentrisme il n'est en revanche plus
possible de nier l'impact négatif d'une
pression et meynac accrue sur notre
biodiversité
alors où 75% des écosystèmes terrestres
et plus de 65% des écosystèmes marins
sont significativement modifiée par
celle ci nous alors que l'épidémie
actuelle constitue un choc pour lequel
les réponses sont rapides et fortes la
crise environnementale est une tendance
sous jacente face à laquelle les
réticences face aux green deal new deal
démontre une fois encore que l'urgence
climatique n'en est finalement pas une
pour de nombreux états et de nombreuses
sociétés hors l'épidémie actuelle est
une crise écologique que l'on pourrait
qualifier dans dauger nelly zecca
retrouvant ses sources dans notre action
et la dégradation préoccupante de la
biodiversité qu'elle provoque perturbant
et chaîne alimentaire des espèces
animales provoquant des changements
comportementaux en un mot augmentant les
risques de les risques de transmission
pathogènes aux humains ainsi monsieur
guy gants face au réchauffement
climatique quels principaux risques
appréhendez-vous entre d'une part
l'import de nouvelles maladies
infectieuses par des insectes vecteurs
dans des zones auparavant épargné et
d'autre part la libéralisation
pathogènes disparues pour lesquelles
nous avons plus d'anticorps
si nous appelons de nos voeux la
définition de mesures novatrices afin de
contrer le changement climatique
pour mouvoir une utilisation plus
respectueuse du territoire ainsi qu'une
économie qui réduisent notre empreinte
environnementale
quel principe de précaution renouveler
préconisez vous en matière sanitaire
merci merci selon joe sur le processeur
je vous invite à répondre à ce bloc de
questions j'ai encore une série de
questions ensuite donc vous aurez
l'occasion de reprendre la parole à
après cette série de réponses
est-ce qu'il peut vous inciter à être
synthétique d'accord merci beaucoup
monsieur le président donc propre
première question pour que c'est
monsieur marchon qui va poser tout
d'abord on à la poser la question enfin
il m'a fait le commentaire du virus
nipah juge voudrait introduire cette
fête
cet exemple de virus nipah est transmis
par dead et des chauves souris géantes
du genre terreau puisse on rencontre en
indonésie et la phénomène de
déforestation pour le développement
d'une culture du palmier à huile les a
chassés de sephora elles sont venues se
réfugier à singapour malaisie et puis un
peu plus tard au bangladesh et à travers
leur urine être transporté dissémine des
particules virales d'un virus
extrêmement pas de jeunes puisque aucun
prix n'est réuni les responsables de
sites responsables de 70 % de mortalité
des individus qui la contractent quand
je parlais dans un entretien dans le
monde où ailleurs 2 et russes encore
plus virulent et pathogènes que celui
qui circule actuellement je faisais
référence à celui là en particulier mais
ce qu'il semble intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui en thaïlande
on est capable de faire tes lisez les
manguiers de manière artificielle de
façon à avoir une production de mangues
dix fois par an vous voyez et or ces
chauves-souris se pose dans les
manguiers parce qu'elles viennent
consommer ces manques dans les vergers
en particulier et donc les urines et
avec ses urines dépose des particules
virales que les porcs peuvent récupérer
et développer une maladie et transmettre
aux éleveurs et aux agriculteurs voilà
présentes dans ces fermes et des vergers
c'est comme ça que la contamination à
travers le pratiquent le développement
de pratiques agricoles à la
fertilisation vous augmenter
l'exposition de personnes qui peuplent
les grèves nra par rapport à ceux à ce
risque là il y en a bien un exemple et
une leaf ration aujourd'hui avec avec
cet exemple n'est pas donc c'est
actuellement en train de travailler par
les collègues du cirad et c'est
justement ce genre de recherche
nous préconisons bien en convient c'est
à dire de voir et de travailler avec la
sur le local qui sont exposés à travers
leurs pratiques et ces nouvelles
pratiques
bien entendu il faut absolument inclure
la dimension la dimension sanitaire mais
quand je parle de dimension sanitaire et
est aussi importante d'inclure tout la
dimension sanitaire et mon propos en
terme de maladies chroniques aussi à
vous voyez il ya les travaux qui ont été
conduits par des collègues de l'inserm
sur les incidences de cas de maladie de
parkinson actuellement en france donc un
travail à travers un travail d'ailleurs
qu'elle est original et assez
exceptionnel il met en évidence que la
distribution des cas de maladie
parkinson
elle est très hautement associés au
développement de pratiques agricoles et
ils vont jusqu'aux autres à certains
détails de quel type d'agriculture
pratiques et pascal galerie culture il
ya eu l'utilisation il ya toujours
l'utilisation de pesticides insecticides
fongicides et donc à l'intérieur des
pratiques agricoles
ils vous parlent bien aussi de certaines
pratiques agricoles et pointe du doigt
la viniculture je suis désolé et à
l'intérieur de la viniculture ce sont
certains vignobles très apprécié qui est
pour lesquels on observe aussi des taux
de maladies de parkinson les plus élevés
qu'en france
mais dans le même temps on observe que
la biodiversité notamment oiseaux on
inspecte la manière très importante
diminué dans ces mêmes régions et on a
des difficultés à faire les liens entre
santé humaine pollution des écosystèmes
des sols de l'eau les liens que l'on
peut faire avec la perte de diversité
biologique alors qu'ils aiment bien une
même raison en amont et c'est très
alarmant je préconise une culture en
territoire d'une compréhension dont nous
avons fourni des documents qui ont été
arrêtés stoppé il ya deux ans en arrière
dans le cas du plan national santé
environnement
nous n'avions faire remonter à un
document avec gilles pipien qui est
ingénieur des ponts et chaussées qui est
directeur de la tl paca
justement d'une culture
d'incompréhension en territoire et des
aspects de sanitaires des populations
humaines en tenant compte des différents
types contre culture des consommations
en particulier et les risques sanitaires
derrière donc c'est vers là qu'il faut
aller je sais que certains ministères il
faut le faire dans un premier temps il
faut aller vers des observatoires et et
sans difficulté les allées et sert ses
relations qui dans un premier temps
seront des corrélations mais qui nous
diront beaucoup aussi dans un même temps
et dans un même territoire à la fois et
taux de maladie de parkinson les taux de
concerts qu'on observe avaient convolé
avec des pertes de l'hiver de
l'université avec des sols et des eaux
qui sont très riches en pesticides
fongicides et d'autres d'autres olemps
et bien illustré leur en ont tiré les
conclusions qu'il faut et je suis tout à
fait d'accord et il faut que celui -
d'orientation en ce sens concernant la
deuxième question qui m'ont été posées
de monsieur coutard je pense questions
agricoles
alors moi dans un premier temps et
notamment au niveau français au niveau
européen donc on parle ici de la
politique en compte française de la
politique à l'école au pn il faut mais
je croyais mort dit rien introduire de
la diversité aujourd'hui nous cultivons
nous utilisons 6 à cette variété des
jeux cas là pour notre production
chacune des variétés végétales
absolument contrôler ce ne serait qu'une
cunin varions à chaque fois c'est à dire
une variété en particulier vous imaginez
que c'est marion soit très sensible à un
virus ou un champignon parasite
introduit sur le sol français et donc
c'est tout le stock de production qui
est le monde sensible parce que nous
avons fabriqué en quelque sorte des
clones donc il faut introduire de la
diversité génétique à tous les étages et
bien entendu concernant les races
animales et les variétés et variétés que
nous produisons on nous semble essentiel
donc ça demande aussi à revoir
très certainement
connect alimentaire rome et le contrôle
de ces variétés etc
alors bon sens et c'est une garantie
c'est une garantie la diversité à la
diversité génétique est une première et
un premier rempart évidemment vous voyez
ce qui se passe actuellement en afrique
où on a aujourd'hui une seule variété de
riz à travers quasiment toute l'afrique
de l'ouest et l'afrique centrale où on a
créé des boulevards de rizières qui ont
favorisé la dissémination d'un virus
qu'on appelle en anglais excusez moi
alors j'ai trouvé en français le virus
de la neige sur jaune du rite est en
train de de faire disparaître énormément
de plants de riz et donc de la
reproduction de la production maury
parce que nous avons qu'un variant alors
qu'il ya trente ans en arrière ne serait
ce qu'au sénégal nous avions parié
chacune complètement adapter à des
contextes de sueur salure de manque de
manque d'eau et donc pour moi ça s'avère
important et on parle bien de diversité
biologique donc introduire la diversité
génétique ça me semble essentiel une
vision en territoire du développement de
l'agriculture élevage comme simple aussi
très important dans le respect des
populations concernant la limitation de
l'élevage intensif on pas le bien de
transition on y rigole
j'ai moi même travaillé dans le grand
ouest français en automne de l'industrie
agroalimentaire offert de l'argent pour
payer mes études
donc je le sais un système que je
connais très bien et pour une période a
cumulé de 2 ans à au nord au nord si on
a mis des des des animaux d'élevage en
chambres dont on est lâché aussi parce
qu'on les a mis sous cloche
donc je le fais référence est exactement
au confinement on a on les a mis aussi
en élevage et en chambre et et ben c'est
aussi pour éviter tout danger infectieux
le danger infectieux il existe lorsque
vous l'introduisait mais si vous
enfermer des animaux dans les chambres
et bien vous éviter toute menace
extérieure dans un premier temps donc
aujourd'hui le retour de troupeaux en
chant nous ne savons pas répondre à très
bien est ce qu ils ne seront pas plus à
risque de menace ne
menaces sanitaires notamment affectionne
est-ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs avec la
pratiquer l'élevage des ovins et les
caprins qui sont aujourd'hui en général
en semi extensif et qui sont très
sensibles à des infections ou des
parasites hausse con comme qu'on ne sait
pas soigner mon très difficilement vous
voyez donc voilà donc il faut y aller
mais progressivement et nous avons
besoin d'un appui
bien entendu pour comprendre cette
transition je parle bien de transition
que ça veut dire ça ne peut pas non plus
se faire du jour au lendemain d'un
passage immédiat et radicale on a besoin
de 6,2 de comprendre il peut y avoir un
risque on va voir les animaux que nous
ayons en chant d'ailleurs ya beaucoup
d'études sur la transmission des grippes
aviaires alors deux collègues
on a deux se sont unis les grands
élevages ni les petits élevages qui sont
plus à risque de transmission de la
guerre ce sont les des élevages de
poulets de moyenne à quoi on a besoin on
a besoin aussi en termes de recherche
refaire ton gris pâle de comprendre sur
cd la galerie alors dernière question de
monsieur longeau je crois en consommant
un changement climatique et les maladies
infectieuses de la recette mon deuxième
sujet de travail c'est quelque chose que
je suis au niveau français et européen
et international et pour travailler et
collaborer avec des musiciens du puma
alors la sucette sur les thèmes on a
beaucoup dit ah vous voyez par exemple
on va vous parler de la remontée du
moustique tigre en france à partir du
sud européen est aujourd'hui présent sur
les départements atlantique ou même au
sud de paris mais le moustique tigre ne
remonte pas à cause du changement
climatique et l'embarquent à chaque fois
que vous venez visiter le sud de la
france que vous ouvrez votre coffre de
voiture et l'embarquent dans votre
coffre et vous le délivrer ensuite
lorsque vous remontez dans les régions
de nantes ou d'auxerre vous voyez est
donc ça ça se pratique aussi avec les
camions qui remonte à bien entendu le
nom et à part les autoroutes mais aussi
le container à cargo sur les 30 et aussi
les avions donc le transport humain est
bien plus important en noir pour
conclure sur cette question et pour
faire rempli d'un article dans le lancet
infectious disease qui essaie de
reprendre dans une méta analyse mais
quelle 155 sans travaux
été fait lors ce changement climatique
est une maladie infectieuse d'être
transmises par des vecteurs 52% des
travaux montrent un effet significatif
du changement climatique ça veut dire
que 48%
on n'en montre pas ou montrent un effet
inverse mais qui parle de les faire j'ai
moi même écrit un article sur bamako en
2050 où les conditions atmosphériques et
climatologique seront elles que la
circulation du paludisme ne pourra plus
se faire parce que trop chaud et pas
assez d'eau alors évidemment c'est
dommage plus assez d'eau les populations
bien entendu ne pourront plus voir mais
ce sont aussi les circonstances qui
devrait limiter la circulation quand du
paludisme noms qui parlent des effets
aussi bénéfique mais quoi qu'on en dise
cette étude vous montre que finalement
on n'en sait pas grand chose
très certainement le sujet a été vue de
manière exagérée et parmi les 52 %
d'agents infectieux qui ont des
distributions plus importante
aujourd'hui est comment on peut
interpréter comme être dû au changement
climatique sur ces 52 % vous voyez c'est
à grand chose et bien 90%
ce sont des études qui n'ont introduit
dans leur sujet d'étude de leur modèle
uniquement que les variants
bioclimatique et aux sorties de modèles
elle révèle que ce sont des variables
bioclimatique qui qui sont importantes
pour comprendre à ces phénomènes mais
non pas confrontés ces variables
climatiques avec des arrières l'entrepôt
logique sociologique politique
nutritionnelle l'importance de lutter
nutritionnelle de la pauvreté donc quand
vous confondez des variables
bioclimatique avec d'autres à rieumes
vous vous apercevez que beaucoup des
maladies pour lesquelles on indique que
le changement climatique avait une
importance et une déviance et sont
plutôt des grands classiques de
l'épidémiologie qui apparaissent et
c'est à dire je vous les ai donné la
taille des populations la densité
populationnelle la pauvreté qui sont
toujours des éléments importants pour
comprendre des maladies infectieuses
leur transmission